the question is one we'll talk about
today and it seemed to make sense at the
end of phase two to talk about the
beginning of phase three and I'm going
to spend just a few minutes talking
about the first two films we have coming
up next year and phase three the first
one that I'm going to talk about today
is called dr. strange dr. strange is a
project that we've been working on since
before the inception of the MCU the goal
of these films is always to continue to
expand what a comic book film is what a
Marvel Cinematic Universe film is and
starting the other couple years ago with
guardians of the galaxy this year with
ant-man next year with Doctor Strange
continuing to push the boundaries of
that cinematic universe a fellow named
Benedict Cumberbatch is playing dr.
Frank
he sent a little greeting just for you
guys
od 23 very very lucky very excited to be
taking on Doctor Strange from our early
look at some of the work that's already
been done
today he's an extraordinary character
and brings in a whole other dimension
multiple dimensions to the Marvel
Universe
you